more than a year after it started
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine
continues to rage on some of those
caught in the middle have made their way
right here to Las Vegas but there's a
big adjustment to life in America eight
news now reporter Victoria Saha shows us
The Help available for them
being stripped of their right to work in
their home country that's the story
behind these people coming to America to
learn simple jobs such as arranging
flowers it's a way they can restart
their lives in a center yeah perfect
24-year-old Maria vansova using flowers
to create a centerpiece a beautiful
sight during a challenging time I loved
Kiev I have friends from Ukraine what
some of us Americans might not expect is
that ven Stova is from Russia the love
between her home country and Ukraine now
lost the war wasn't happening in Russia
but people could feel it Vince Tova
tells me if Russian showed any
opposition to what their president is
doing they would lose their jobs once
you talk about it you're in danger which
is why she needed to flee her journey
from Moscow starting last year going
first to the Dominican Republic then
Costa Rica followed by Peru then Mexico
then Utah and now Las Vegas there's
nothing that keeps them safe here if
they don't have any ways to survive in a
in American society all with the help of
Miriam Lopez founder of non-profit group
land to land Lopez is helping a handful
of refugees adjust to the workforce by
employing them at her event planning
business and learn the American culture
today we were walking on the street and
one guy he was like good morning you all
how are you doing in Russia you'll never
see that she puts together different
flowers a symbol of her wish for peace I
want to hope that there is an end and
there is I just don't see where and when